das was wir da gerade erleben in
bestimmten Freibädern ist komplett in
diskutabel das braucht eine harte klare
Antwort es muss eine klare Grenzziehung
geben bis hierhin und nicht weiter und
diese Grenze ist das Recht und natürlich
das Leute friedlich in einem Freibad
gehen können gerade bei diesen
Temperaturen natürlich muss man schauen
dass ähm auch in die Jugend und
Sozialarbeit investiert wird wird gerade
in Berlin unter den schwarzen gestrichen
in Neukölln beispielsweise aber es geht
natürlich auch darum dass die Polizei
gut ausgestattet sein muss und dass die
Richterschaft auch schnell diese Themen
auch angehen kann und wenn ich das
richtig sehe haben die letzten Jahre die
schwarzen Sheriff in diesem Land so
viele Polizei Stellen abgebaut dass die
Polizei über 20 Millionen Überstunden
angehäuft hat dass sie gestresst ist
überfordert ist teilweise mit einzelnen
Situation das Polizei Kräfte fehlen ist
ein riesen Missstand in diesem Land das
müssen